I think they're starting to.
Let's listen in.
you pretend you're in a bind.
in a plea of not guilty
a plea of not guilty.
Mr.
Summers, I see that there is
you haven't to my client, Judge
Charles Summers, We interpret
the way boring the indictment in which we
might feel can happen
in the morning.
Judge Mathis. Mr.
Mills, we wait for you on the indictment.
If you're a not guilty plea,
each of your attorneys
have entered a plea
of not guilty on your behalf.
You understand that
despite everyone's best effort
this case may take some time.
You're going to be receiving a discovery
on how voluminous the discovery is.
It may take some time
for the state
reflect all turned over to your attorneys
or your attorneys
to review that discovery
and to prepare their motions
and prepare their case.
So be patient.
Work with your attorneys, cooperate
with them, meet with them,
go over the discovery.
Make sure that if there are any delays,
that these delays are on account
of any of your actions.
To those also in attendance.
As I've explained to the defendants,
this case can take some time.
But we do ask for your patience
continued patience,
your continued civility.
In this case, we understand that there
may be some
high emotions
in this case,
but we ask that you continue.
You be patient with us.
Everyone involved
wants this case to be completed
as quickly as possible.
But it's important
for you all
to understand
the state of Tennessee, as well
as each one of these defendants,
have an absolute right to a fair trial.
And I will not allow any
behavior that could jeopardize that right
So with that being said, we thank you all
for being present tonight.
State understanding
that there may be some discovery
that needs to be collected.
We are going to continue this phase out
a little bit
further to make sure that
this government, including
we're going to present this matter
until May 1st
nine, a
state.
Is there anything else?
The only other thing on behalf of this
state is
I have a protective
order as each of the defendants
to allow certain
digital discovery video evidence to
be provided.
Any objection may Know.
Jesse Jackson.
Thank you, John.
Okay.
Is there anything else
on behalf of your client?
No, Your Honor.
We did follow our motion recovery
just more.
Anything on that?
No, no, no, Your Honor.
But we did file a motion for particulars
pursuant to Rule seven.
C, Tennessee Rules of Procedure.
And nothing further this morning,
Your Honor.
Think the stomach program that morning.
All right, gentlemen.
We will stay back here May 1st
on that day,
and we will now use
the defense of their defense counsel.
We're asking everyone else
in the
of to remain in the courtroom
remain seated.
With regard to everybody else,
I would like the court knows
the family is here
Thank you for your up
until you there
you have it all
five former
officers entering pleas of not guilty.
Former federal prosecutor
Shan will, former
Boston police commissioner
Ed Davis with us.
So, Shan, at this point,
of course,
as we just heard, May 1st,
everybody will be back.
The judge warning
this may take some time.
Understandable in this case.
But as we move forward here,
what's remarkable and Shimon
brought this up again
the D.A., of course, talking to CNN about
and we and we learned this
a couple weeks ago
that prosecutors are now reviewing
a number of cases that involve
these former officers all cases
where criminal charges
were brought by the d.A.
Some closed, some pending.
Is that standard
in a situation like this?
Well, there's not too much
that is standard about this type
of revealing violence,
having a lot of police
corruption, task force
reviewing these kinds of cases.
You certainly would want to look
at the individual history
of these officers.
What other types of discipline issues,
whether the types
of allegations of violence.
And it sounds like some reporting
there have been here.
So it's very smart to look at that.
It's important to uncover that truth.
From a prosecutorial strategy standpoint,
of course,
the more allegations
they find that could be charged,
the more leverage
they have on getting these officers one
or more to plead guilty
even if they don't go to the point
of indicting the mere fact
that they're looking at this.
They'll be talking to the defense lawyers
about it.
You know, a lot of time to this.
It may take some time to judge there.
And next meeting May 1st, Ed Davis.
The sad fact is
that as we're watching
the legal ramifications of this case,
we had a story on last hour about another
case, this one in Louisiana,
negligent homicide
now charged in the case of Alonzo Bagley.
I don't want to give the impression
that this happens
in every police encounter
there are hundreds of them every day
that end peacefully.
But there clearly is still an issue here.
And I wonder,
are departments training
or are they changing their training
or they're changing their approach
to make these kinds of deadly encounters
less likely
Well, that's a great question, Jim.
After talking to my colleagues
across the country,
I know that this is the single
most important thing
that they are struggling with right now.
Training is a big part of it.
A bigger part of
it is the culture of the organization.
So everybody's
reflecting on what they're doing
and how they are doing it.
But, you know, the the
the advent of cameras has
has brought a lot more accountability.
We have to
we have to be
happy with the fact
that these officers were charged
so quickly
and are being held accountable.
And that sends a message out
to every officer
that's out on the street,
you know, in terms of that culture, too.
And I'm glad you brought that up,
because we have some reporting
when it comes to
there's been a lot made of this Scorpion
unit of which these officers
were members.
And Chief Davis in Memphis was saying
specifically talked about the culture,
saying culture is something,
not something that changes overnight.
So, Shannon, how much is that culture
how much do you anticipate
that culture is going to come into play?
Is going to be part of what we will hear
from both sides
It's a very interesting question.
From a defense standpoint,
you would want as little of that culture
to come in as possible
because your argument would be
that's highly prejudicial
to portray these officers
as being part of a group,
almost a gang member mentality,
where they're just jumping out
and beating up people.
Now, on the other
hand, from the prosecution standpoint.
Obviously,
that type of picture is very important.
The point helps show the jury
what's really going on here.
And the prosecution will be arguing that
this is not simply trying to damage
the officer's reputation,
but rather to show
that these are the facts going on here.
And that's central to proving the intent,
what they were doing wrong.
And that's critical
for the jury to understand.
It's not just an isolated incident,
and that's
what the prosecution's
point is going to be.
So there'll be quite a clash there.
Ed Davis,
you say you're speaking to departments
around the country.
I wonder, as you see
it, becoming more likely for officers
to face murder charges in many cases?
We saw that with George Floyd.
We're seeing it now.
Tyre Nichols,
we see it in the case of Alonzo
Bagley here.
Is that
danger right or that
threat, that consequence?
A motivator for police departments
to change,
not just regulations and training,
but but the culture that you talk about
Well, it certainly is
the sort of Damocles
is hanging over the head of any officer
that acts like this.
And and they've got to know
that at this point in time.
So, you know, friends
that I've been in the business with,
we just shake our heads
that this is still happening.
It just it's inconceivable
that someone doesn't understand
the danger, first of all.
I mean, the humanity of this,
which is that
should be the driving force,
but just a danger to yourself.
If you
if you go if you if you go this far.
There are studies that need to be done
on what happens
physiologically to an officer
after a pursuit or a gun battle.
There's not enough information on that.
None of that is an excuse
but it might be a way to to to deal with
the issues that drive this
kind of behavior.